es ist ein ironisches Element dieses
Krieges dass die Geheimdienste die ja
sehr viel Geld dafür bekommen eigentlich
bessere Informationen zu haben bisher
eigentlich keine haben also wenn ich
jetzt mal überlege was ist alles
prognostiziert worden von von gewissen
generellen die gesagt haben militärisch
ist die Sache gelaufen bis hin zu den
Statements den es geht ja ohne Ukraine
dies aus oder Ukraine kann nicht
gewinnen oder Tralala ich bin
mittlerweile sehr sehr sehr gelassen
geworden gegenüber diesen intelligence
berichten ich gucke mir einfach an was
passiert konkret Objektiv auf dem
Schlachtfeld soweit ihr es jedenfalls
beobachten können und da würde ich sagen
gibt's im Moment eigentlich wenig Grund
zu Pessimismus ich würde sagen
diejenigen die im Moment ein Problem
haben sie die Russen weil ihr Material
im Raum Bach massiv abgenutzt wird weil
sie jede Fähigkeit zu Offensive
verlieren